[Música]
bom dia pessoal meu nome é françois
baroin não é se ficar só ali hoje venham
falar contar para você é minha história
ao empreendedorismo
eu casei aqui no brasil quatro filhos
aqui no brasil e brasileiro e indiano de
sair de lá
nós vamos contar o pessoal
a gente está noite a gente passando uma
dificuldade porque eu estava estudando
engenharia florestal em república
dominicana e eu acabei de chegar no
haiti de 2010 e foi no capital ficando o
tempo ali e depois eu sair não
no anterior para visitar minha família
que está no interior e depois um dia e
chegou a passar o terremoto no haiti que
destruiu o haiti a maior parte do país
a capital porto príncipe e se nesse
fenômeno tem como 250 mil pessoas que
ficam feliz a e um é milhões e meio
estavam desabrigadas
ah e também tem como lesem tentou mil
pessoas que morreram nessa tragédia
pessoal
essas foto que vocês vialle em como
destruir o país
whiting meu país natal é um país pobre
mais pobre da américa central
o pessoal para ter uma ideia uma noção
olha só a quantidade de mortos aquele
momento que aconteceu não nesse fenômeno
a éter exemplo ou e 16 mil pessoas
mortas ou mortas na ter uma noção
pessoal
a maior parte destes mortos como palavra
ativamente com a população do da jaraguá
do sul que é 1.100 77 mil habitantes que
está vivendo em jaraguá do sul sabe uma
parte maior que foram perdendo a vida
aquele momento no haiti
depois o terremoto
a vida da gente ficar insustentável no
país
a gente não vê como poder fazer eu como
a gente tá vai estudando em república
dominicana a gente não ter comum e
continuar a estudar porque o recurso
nosso está destruindo a ali que a gente
te começar a pensar de outra maneira
a minha esposa que estava trabalhando e
como comércio na rua a se o dinheiro que
a gente tinha foi perdido no banco é a
gente tinha casa também foi destruído
mas a gente é um sortudo que está vivo
ainda
olha só tanta gente disse desabrigado 11
milhões e meio
há ali essas pessoas que vocês vêem no
fotos assim são pessoas abrigadas estão
subindo
os móveis mais próximo para construir
barracões para sobreviver para morar com
a família deles tá bom tom
nessa situação o que fazer
eu como a gente estava pensando como
empreendedor a cabeça pensa de outra
maneira
minha primeira meta é terminar meu
estudo a engenharia e água foi instalado
na empresa pública dominicano que a
fronteira do haiti
portanto não é possível porque nós o
recurso que tá país natal foram
destruindo tudo
já a gente pensar de outra maneira e eu
tinha um amigo que estava pesquisando
que tá vendo que o governo do brasil
estava fazendo um acordo com o governo
do haiti
lá a receber ou refugiado haitiano
aqui no brasil chegue no brasil
lá não há a e esperando comum mais ou
menos dois meses ali não acabe no
refugiado para esperar a documentação
antes de mais para frente no brasil
ali a gente conseguir a carteira de
trabalho cpf ea gente ter possibilidade
para andar mais à frente
chega em santa catarina só o são miguel
do oeste que é é perto do início ali a
gente ficar 2 de dois anos
trabalhando não como servente na
construção civil a trabalhando ali da
constituição civil trabalhando depois e
depois de oito meses a gente tentar a
trazer meu esposa que estavam ficando lá
no haiti
tá ali que
depois veio ela chega lá não são miguel
dois passaram um bom tempo ali a gente
não consigo e trabalho para ela a e ali
a gente começar a pensar de outra
maneira
falar que a gente mudar de cidade
eu tinha um professor é que estava
trabalhando no iff
eu conversei com ele e ele começar a me
ajudar a pesquisar um lugar que tem mais
emprego e mais tranquilidade
falar que a gente mudar de cidade e
conseguimos achar o jaraguá do sul
ali já não quando chegar em jaraguá do
sul a gente começar a buscar trabalho
começar a entregar ficha fazer cadastro
num na agência
a ea gente sucessivamente a cada dia
mais a gente tá na rua procurando
emprego e procurando emprego procurando
emprego e depois um dia chegou que a
gente chegar
uma empresa que a gente fui e
cumprimentou a moça além e eu pedir o
favor
vocês se receber currículo há aqui nós
não contratamos estrangeiro eu dizer a
verdade
se não contratar estrangeiros e eu
agradecer e fui a moça fica na porta e
vigiava até que eu saí
no portão tá ela tal viajando a mim
o que eu perdi o chão dessa empresa e
chegar à forma e à livre 1
o que chamar o desespero
a gente começar a pensar eu disse que eu
não vou procurar mais emprego
eu vou sair do brasil
eu não acreditava se poderá acontecer
isso
porque a gente está procurando emprego
falar sua cala a sustentar a família
assim que a gente estava pensando
mas eu lembrei que uma lição que a gente
lê como empreendedor defendeu não é toda
essas pessoas que vai receber a gente
que vai olhar para nós como estrangeiro
a olho nu que o pessoal vai receber mal
também
esse não é o fim da vida em que ergue a
cabeça e continuar mais pra frente
a laac falar que a gente alcançar com
nossa meta
a meta é sustentar a família que é
primeiramente que é necessário falar a
consegui atingir com nossa meta que está
futuramente de veneno outras coisas a
mais na nossa vida
ali que a gente começar a movimentar a
se falar aqui em jaraguá
ver outra idéia que a gente começa a
pensar para criar uma associação a criar
essa associação com que objetivo pessoal
esse objetivo alá criar a associação
para lá lutar contra a desigualdade
social a a fazer a inclusão social nas
ruas na cidade de jaraguá do sul
o comandante a movimentar pessoal como
está fazendo reunião a primeira da união
que a gente fez nós ficamos três pessoas
depois a gente começar a pensar escrever
as idéias e começar com vida pessoal ali
que nós convidamos e até que a gente
chega não e fiquei fazendo gol é essa a
imagem que você vai ver ali que a gente
chega lá não é isso que fazendo um
grande
a associação tem nome como esboço freado
que define como a associação de
movimento social do site à noite a água
doce no painel e do brasil
principalmente em jaraguá do sul
inicialmente em jaraguá do sul
e nós corremos atrás e consegui um
terreno através da prefeitura falar ter
uma horta comunitária
nessa hora a gente começar a mexer lá
sobreviver o que cê já não consigo o
emprego rapidamente mas com esta horta
como a gente tem conhecimento não
questão e agroflorestal a gente começar
a andar mais para frente e começar a
planta se você olhar ali ver como a
gente está trabalhando na hora de
começar a fazer uma é
aqui o pessoal em jaraguá do sul vê
pessoal na outro olho não é
não do jeito que eles pensam que nós
temos o outra experiência outra
alternativa a onde que nós começa a onde
que nós vamos pessoal ali a gente pensa
para ser professor também de france a
a gente começar a tentar vencer
na verdade é professor de infantis mas
como tem muitas pessoas que não
interessem a aprender francês
a gente não conseguia a quantidade de o
aluno palla ensinar a mas no entanto a
gente começava a ensinar com 2 aluno
inicia aumente
e assim a gente começar a sair à frente
assim o pessoal a vida dos estrangeiro
não é fácil se refugiado mismo não é
fácil no qualquer países qualquer cor
o país estrangeiro não é fácil só que
não ficar com raiva ganha esperar que um
dia vocês vai atende ou o objetivo do
seu metas pessoal
hoje em dia
estou aqui contando essa história pra
vocês
eu tenho colagem falar contar essa
história vocês
não somente palavras vocês ouvir mas a
vocês entendem quando uma pessoa está
num país estrangeiro como ficar a
situação o que seja preto negro
o trato pessoal
ali
hoje
para mim essa história que eu contei pra
você eu queria que vocês ficam ou seja é
pensar de outra maneira porque se vocês
não passar nesse caminho
pode acontecer que vocês têm um filho ou
uma família um membro de sua família que
vai passar nesse caminho
eu agradeço a vocês pela atenção
obrigado
[Música]